The Conservation Fund is a national non-profit organization...
...operating across all 50 states.
We are chartered for both conservation and economic development.
We are able to increase the economic opportunities for rural communities,...
...their timber harvesting while also protecting the forest...
...and all of nature's benefits.
As we watched more than a million acres of forest land...
...come on the market each year,...
...we realized we needed a new approach.
The collaboration between Goldman Sachs and the Conservation Fund...
...is a great example of progress.
The Conservation Fund...
...issued the nation's first green bond for conservation with Goldman Sachs...
...and together, we helped invent a new way...
...of going to scale protecting these magnificent lands.